hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime uproar and Deku squirk
one for all is one of the most important
and most overpowered quirks in the
entire story it has changed a lot over
time allowing Deku to unlock seven
different quirks altogether and it is
still changing and evolving right now in
fact horikoshi has been dropping hints
about the true tragic nature of one for
all for the past 200 chapters and I will
break it all down for you right now if
you guys enjoy our mha content and you
want to see more in the future leave a
quick like and comment right now it only
takes you a second but it really helps
us out with that YouTube algorithm and
if you are one of the over 50 of people
who watch our videos but haven't taken
the time to subscribe yet do me a big
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
to turn on all notifications quick thank
you to raid Shadow Legends first
sponsoring this video wanna play an
awesome free game with over 650
Champions badass bosses and PVP battles
and also support this Channel at the
same time just use my QR code or link
below to download raid on mobile or PC
raid has amazing new things happening
this month including a new legendary
champion available in game right now
Ronda Rousey seriously legendary MMA
fighter Ronda Rousey has become a raid
Champion she's a badass Gladiator with
fists of fire and she's got a bunch of
multi-hits kills making her perfect for
taking on bosses like the Fire Knight
better yet her second skill blocks both
active and passive skills and that'll
help you shut down those super tough
Arena teams how great is that you can
get Ronda for free right now whether
you're new or a long time player just
log in and play raid for seven days
between now and February 28th and
Rhonda's yours to celebrate ronda's
arrival use the special promo code raid
Rhonda to get a bunch of helpful stuff
perfect for leveling up your Ronda also
if you're an Amazon Prime member you can
get your exclusive rewards in raid right
now new players use my link or scan the
QR code right here and get a free
starter pack worth almost thirty dollars
a free champion Aina and also this cool
in-game loot you will find your rewards
here in your inbox for the next 30 days
only so check it out Link in the
description finally this video will
contain Boku no hero manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned one for all is a completely
unique Quirk that is actually the
product of two different quirks
accidentally coming together into one
one for all has the extremely rare
ability to be transferred from one user
to another as long as the current user
willingly allows his successor to
consume some of their DNA this can be
their blood a strand of their hair or
you know other stuff that we won't get
into here the quirk one for all was
created by accident by the villain all
for one all for one had a younger
brother named yoichi shigaraki and back
when all for one first launched his bid
to take over Japan and the world his
younger brother couldn't accept this
plan and he decided to oppose him now at
this point everyone believed that all
for one's younger brother yoichi was
born quirkless because he never had a
quirk manifest in any visible way all
for one thought that one of the reasons
why his younger brother didn't support
his plan was because he didn't have a
quirk so he couldn't understand why all
for one's actions were Justified all for
one believed that the best way to end
the chaos and destruction that emerged
as a result of the sudden appearance of
quirks was for him to seize power and
force everyone to abide by his will all
for one was of course born with an
extremely powerful Quirk which is also
named all for one this Quirk allowed him
to steal the quirks of others and then
either use them himself or transferred
them to someone else this includes the
possibility of stealing multiple quirks
at once and then using all of them at
the same time since he was born with one
of the most overpowered quirks of all
time all for one did not think that his
brother yoichi was any sort of threat to
him and in fact he actually felt bad for
his weak and helpless sibling so all for
one decided to transfer one of the
quirks that he stole into his brother
against his brother's will The Quirk he
transferred to yoichi allowed the user
to stockpile power inside his body and
then eventually this stockpiled power
could be released in super human bursts
of strength and speed however
unbeknownst to all for one and even his
brother yuichi himself yuichi was not
born quirkless all for one's younger
brother was born with a very particular
Quirk that was present within him but
never manifested in any noticeable way
this Quirk gave its user the ability
ability to willingly transfer to Quirk
itself onto someone else but that seemed
to be its only real power all it could
do is transfer itself onto someone else
which on its own had no real effect but
after all for one transferred that
stockpiling Quirk into his brother's
body the two Quirk factors merged and
the transferring Quirk and the
stockpiling Quirk transformed into a
single Quirk a quirk that we know today
as one for all this means that one for
all is not a naturally occurring Quirk
it is a quirk that was artificially
created albeit by accident upon
receiving the stockpiling Quirk all for
one's brother yoichi didn't have a
change of heart like all for one had
been hoping for instead of coming over
to his brother's side he used his
Newfound power to actively oppose his
older brother even more fervently but
yoichi simply wasn't strong enough to
defeat All For One and eventually all
for one killed him in battle but before
yoichi died he managed to transfer his
Quirk onto another person who had also
been fighting against all for one and
this person then became the second one
for all user when all for one eventually
realized that his brother's Quirk had
been transferred on to someone else he
decided to steal it for himself as a
result all for one made it his mission
to hunt down every subsequent one for
all user while he did kill five of them
on top of yuichi he never managed to
steal one for all because each user was
able to transfer the Quirk to someone
else before dying and because one of the
two quirks that came together to form
one for all was a stockpiling Quirk the
one for all Quirk continued to stockpile
power with each passing year and with
each new user meaning that it eventually
became stronger over time remember that
fact because it will become come very
important as we explore the true nature
of one for all and where the evolution
of this Quirk could be heading because
one for all kept getting stronger over
many decades and generations by the time
it reached the eighth one for all user
toshinoriyagi AKA almight it was strong
enough to actually defeat All For One
well a lot of the credit has to go to
almight himself because he had a
naturally powerful body and incredible
determination the previous users were
all aware that one for all was getting
stronger and in fact the only former
user prior to all might who didn't die
in battle against all for one and the
villains was the fourth user hikage
shinomori hikage knew that he had no
hope of defeating all for one but he
also knew that one for all had the
potential to get strong enough to defeat
him one day so instead of trying to take
all for one head on hikage lived in a
forest in the middle of nowhere as a
Hermit he lived there for 18 years while
trying to make one for all stronger and
he eventually died of old age the only
problem is that he died of old age at
the age of 40. because one for all was
actually depleting his life force much
faster than normal thanks to the fourth
user's personal experience we learned
that if someone who already has a quirk
inherits one for all their life force
will deplete quickly and they will live
a much shorter life than normal just
like he could get so the ideal candidate
for inheriting one for all is actually
someone who was born quirkless and as we
know both almight and Deku work Reckless
at Birth that is why almight was able to
use one for all for like 40 years
without dying it is important to note
that from the time of one for all's
creation to the time it was inherited by
almight All For One tried to steal the
Quirk many times but he failed every
time that is because one for all can
only be transferred voluntarily leave
from one user to another so even though
all for one has a quirk that can
literally steal the quirks of others he
still couldn't steal one for all as we
eventually find out the Vestige of each
former one for all user remained within
the one for all Quirk as it was passed
down from one user to another and these
vestiges these fragments of the original
user's Consciousness act as guardians of
one for all and they are able to prevent
it from being stolen that said all for
one believes that he's finally figured
out a way to steal one for all he
believes that the overwhelming Rage of
shigaraki tomura will be able to
overtake Juan for all's defenses
overcome the vestiges and finally steal
the Quirk and that brings us to the
ninth and current user of one for all
izuku midoriya AKA Deku even though one
for all has been changing evolving and
getting stronger in the many generations
patients prior to the Quirk being
inherited by Deku the evolution of one
for all really kicks into high gear
after Deku becomes the ninth user when
he initially inherited The Quirk Deku
had an extremely difficult time
controlling it and he would hurt himself
pretty badly every time he tried to use
it these injuries include breaking his
fingers and limbs so we're not just
talking about a few cuts and bruises
here we're talking about injuries that
required serious medical attention
nevertheless as a result of intense
training incredible dedication and firm
guidance from both all might and Gran
Torino Deku eventually learned how to
control how much of one for all's power
he uses when he attacks and he learned
how to use his Quirk effectively without
constantly injuring himself when Deku
finally Masters the use of his quirk in
a way that allows him to stay out of the
hospital he is able to practice with it
and discover its true potential and
insane versatility one for all gives
Deku the ability to release enormous
amounts of stockpiled raw power which
effectively gives him super strength and
super speed as well as superhuman
agility and durability the user can
control what percentage of this
stockpiled power is released at any
given time he can focus more power
within certain parts of his body if he
chooses such as an arm or a leg or he
can just choose to distribute all the
power throughout his body as I mentioned
earlier one for all in the present time
is much stronger than it was initially
because it has been stockpiling more and
more power over the course of many
decades which means that Deku now has
access to way more power than some of
the former one for all users Deku is
also the first and only user who is able
to unlock the quirks of all the former
one for all users it turns out that the
core of the one for all Quirk had fused
with the Quirk factors of all the
previous one for all users who actually
had their own Quirk and this means that
Deku is eventually able to gain access
to six other quirks in addition to one
for all itself there have been nine one
for all users all together but since
Deco and all might are quirkless and the
first user yoichi was the original one
for all user there are six other users
whose quirk's Deku is able to unlock we
don't know why exactly Deku is the only
one who is able to do this but it's
likely related to the fact that one for
all keeps getting stronger and after all
the power that all might had poured into
it over the course of 40 years The Quirk
has gotten strong enough to reach a
completely different stage of evolution
and that Evolution includes the active
manifestation of the other six quirks
within the current one for all user Deku
is able to unlock these additional
quirks one by one over the course of
about 150 chapters starting with black
whip in chapter 210 of the manga black
whip allows its user to generate black
10 drills from their body and use these
tendrils to either attack an opponent
restrain an opponent or increase the
versatility of the user's own movements
Deku would also go on to unlock float a
quirk that allows him to levitate
through the air danger sense which
allows its user to instantly identify
imminent threats in the surrounding
areas like a spidey sense smoke screen
which allows its user to generate smoke
and severely reduce his opponent's
visibility on the battlefield VA Jin
which allows its user to build up
kinetic energy in their body by
repeating regular movements and this
energy can then be stored up and used
later and gear shift which allows its
user to shift the speed of anything he
touches he can use it on himself to make
his own movements much faster and he can
also use it to shift the speed of his
opponent after making direct contact
with him it is important to note that
all of these quirks are much stronger
now than they were back when they were
being used by their original users and
that is because the growing strength of
one for all itself has made all of these
additional query works much more
powerful as well so for instance the
second user's Quirk gear shift is now in
a completely different League from what
it was when the second user had been
using it all for one who actually fought
the second user personally many decades
ago could hardly even recognize gear
shift when he saw Deku using it in the
present time The Quirk is just so much
stronger now that it's practically
unrecognizable and not only are all
these quirks stronger but they can also
be combined in extremely effective ways
for example combining float with one for
all's ability to propel Yourself by
unleashing an incredible amount of power
turns what is essentially levitation
into high speed flight smoke screen can
be combined with danger sense to
completely obstruct your opponent's
Vision while you still have a good idea
of what's going on thanks to Danger
sense and not only can the separate
effects of different quirks be combined
but multiple completely different quirks
can actually create brand new super
moves for instance black whip can be
paired with fajin to create a new super
move called black chain once we get to
the final Arc of the story Deku is
already extremely skilled in combining
his seven different quirks on the
battlefield and he seems to be only
getting better at this as the manga
approaches its conclusion nevertheless
even this ability to use and masterfully
combine seven different quirks may not
be the end of one for all's evolution in
fact I think that horikoshi has been
hinting that one for all is about to
undergo yet another major Evolution ever
since chapter
166 of the manga so over 200 chapters
ago as of the making of this video I am
referring to the Quirk Singularity
Theory also known as The Quirk
Singularity doomsday Theory and the
Paranormal Singularity Theory this
theory was first developed some 70 years
ago by Dr Hyundai garaki also known as
Dr ujiko it states that as time passes
and different Quirk users reproduce with
each other the quirks of their children
will blend together the quirks of the
parents and evolve even further creating
much more powerful and complex quirks
eventually these quirks will become so
overwhelmingly powerful that they will
be difficult for their users to control
and that's because the human body
doesn't evolve as quickly as quirks do
meaning that a normal human body simply
cannot handle such powerful new quirks
one day children will be born with
quirks that are unbelievably strong and
impossible for their bodies to control
and this will eventually lead to a
doomsday scenario where everyone becomes
a threat to everyone else and Chaos
ensues horikoshi has deliberately placed
on emphasis on the fact that kids in the
world of mha seem to be getting stronger
and possess even more powerful quirks
than the older Generations which was of
course an early hint that The Quirk
Singularity theory has real Merit Eddie
in particular was a crucial early
example of the rapid and dangerous
evolution of quirks her Quirk rewind is
completely different from the quirks
possessed by both of her parents it is
not just some basic blending of their
two quirks it is an outright Evolution
and because rewind manifested when Arie
was still just a child she accidentally
rewound her own father out of existence
and there was nothing that she or anyone
else could do about it the Quirk
Singularity theory stipulates that cases
like Arie are just the beginning and in
the future such cases will become more
and more common and more and more
dangerous so hints about Quirk
Singularity have been there for a very
long time but the theory was practically
confirmed to be true in chapter
347. that is when shigaraki reveals a
strange new ability that he is able to
use even while all of his quirks are
actively being erased by monoma and
Eraserhead after undergoing a bunch of
experimental procedures on his body in
order to allow his body to accommodate a
myriad of different quirks including all
for one shigaraki's body his very flesh
begins to mutate independently of the
effects of any single Quirk this
mutation takes the form of scores of
giant fingers first sprouting on one of
his arms and then all over his body
these fingers continue to multiply until
they practically overtake the entire
Battlefield and anyone trying to take
shiraki on in battle has to First deal
with this seemingly endless Forest of
fingers and hands that just keeps
growing shigaraki can use these
mutations both to attack others and to
defend himself by forming a protective
armor around his body apparently this
mutation is the result of shigaraki's
body instinctively transforming into its
optimal shape the perfect shape for
shigaraki to accomplish his goals
because he is so determined to destroy
the world around him the mutation
manifests in the form of a constantly
growing mountain of fingers that can
consume everything and of course once
shigaraki gets the power to use Decay
again this mutation will allow him to
generate an incredible amount of
Destruction very quickly having said
that it stands to reason that someone
else whose body attains Quirk
Singularity and who has a different
personality and different life goals
from shigaraki will see their body
mutate in completely different ways and
that brings us back to Deku as far as
shigaraki goes all for one and ujiko
knew that his body would struggle to
accommodate all the new quirks that were
going to be transferred into him
including all for one itself so they
made extensive alterations to his body
as part of a procedure that took several
months to complete and in fact initially
it wasn't complete shigaraki had to wake
up earlier than planned due to the
heroes raiding the lab in jakku 2 and
then he had to take extra time for his
body to actually reach 100 percent Peak
Performance Jack who hasn't had any
fancy body alterations in order to allow
him to accommodate additional quirks
other than training his body as much as
possible and learning to use all the
different quirks in his Arsenal but Deku
is still a quirkless individual who
ended up manifesting seven different
quirks and not only did he unlock seven
quirks but due to the stockpiling nature
of one for all all of these quirks are
far more powerful now than they had been
originally and as one for all continues
to get stronger and as Deku continues to
use and overuse all his different quirks
against shigaraki and the villains it is
very likely that his own body will also
reach the point of Quirk Singularity he
will get to the point where his own body
begins to mutate in order to accommodate
all seven of his overpowered quirks and
in order for him to attain his own
optimal shape just like shigaraki I
believe that when this happens all seven
of deku's quirks will merge into one
single super Quirk what I mean by this
is that I don't think he will keep using
all of his different quirks separately
and then combine them with each other as
he has been doing up to this point I
think that they will simply merge into
one into one single completely broken
power and after this happens Deku will
no longer need to think about using one
Quirk or another or combining one Quirk
with another all of the different powers
and abilities embedded in all of these
different quirks will fuse into a single
power that Deku will be able to unleash
instinctively without even thinking
about it and that power will likely take
a form that is completely different from
everything that we've seen up to this
point I'm imagining something like Deku
entering Sage of Six Paths mode and
maybe even going berserk for a while
until he learns to actually control that
power at that early stage he might even
be dangerous to the people around him
him as uncontrollable Quirk Singularity
Powers surges through him without any
proper direction this Unleashed final
evolution of one for all could take a
tragic turn and it could be a serious
threat to Deku and to everyone around
him before he learns to control this
power Deku may not be himself he may be
a far more Savage and ruthless character
from the Deku that we're used to but in
the end I have to believe that the real
Deku will regain control this is after
all a Shonen so we don't have to worry
about Deku like going berserk and taking
out all of his classmates although we
could see him seriously injure some of
the villains and then feeling bad about
it later once he gets back in control I
also believe that like shigaraki upon
reaching Quirk Singularity deku's body
May mutate and change in a way that
reflects his personality and his
ultimate goals in life shigaraki wants
to destroy the world with his own hands
so that is why his mutation is just a
bunch of figures and hands growing and
spreading and consuming everything but
Deku wants to protect everyone and save
everyone he wants to be the greatest
hero so his mutation would look a lot
different I'm picturing him growing
extra limbs or maybe some sort of
tentacles that would allow him to
protect and save a bigger number of
people at the same time or maybe he will
be able to produce some sort of armor or
energy shield from his body protecting
others and saving everyone seems to be
his top priority so that's why I'm
picturing these types of mutations what
do you guys think will one for all
evolve into a new and completely
different Quirk as a result of Quirk
Singularity will deku's body begin to
mutate just like shigarakis and if so
what kind of mutation do you think that
deku's body will undergo drop a comment
with your theories down below and I will
turn the coolest idea for deku's
mutation and final form into an artwork
that will be featured in a future video
If you guys enjoyed this Boku no hero
video and you want to see more in the
future leave a quick like and comment
right now it only takes you a second but
it helps a lot with that YouTube
algorithm and if you happen to be one of
the over 50 of people who watch my
videos but are not subscribed to the
Channel please do me a big favor and
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification Bell to turn
on all notifications you might have
watched a few of my videos and now
they're getting recommended on YouTube
and you think that you don't have to
subscribe but realistically YouTube will
stop recommending our videos if you
don't subscribe and you're gonna miss a
ton of them so definitely subscribe you
can also hit me up on Twitter and
Instagram at animeoproar thanks again to
raid Shadow Legends for sponsoring this
video check them out to link in the
description as always thank you guys so
much for watching and until next time
see ya Space Cowboys